[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de périgueux le
château de caussade sert de cadre à l'un
des nouveaux épisodes des aventures
d'arsène lupin un film dont les vedettes
sans sophie agacinski henri virlojeux et
bien entendez georges descrières lui
paie en titre depuis quatre ans à la fin
de cet épisode le célèbre comédien
bordelais aura tourné le onzième film de
cette série et ce sera quelque peu
identifiée à son illustre personnage on
né pendant trois quatre mois après la
projection de passage des films d'arsène
lupin en et arsène lupin et après je
dirais pas qu'on vous oublie mais les
gens pensent à autre chose car il ya
d'autres films qui passent à la
télévision d'autres pratiques rozier
cette nouvelle série est réalisée par
jean pierre des années il tournera trois
épisodes en périgord
mais à qui ce qui est une comédie un peu
à la feydeau celui je tue en ce moment
qui s'appelle allochtone se lance un
défi
il y en a un qui se passe pendant la
période de la chasse les huit coups de
l'horloge qui a pour cadre la chasse et
puis le troisième qui est la demeure
mystérieuse qui est une histoire qui se
passe plus la lan plus dans une ville
que dans un que dans un extérieur
[Applaudissements]
arsène lupin est le prototype du héros
populaire français on a beau titre
d'ailleurs que d'artagnan des trois
mousquetaires ou que du comte de monte
cristo que fanfan la tulipe
parce que c'est vraiment notre robin des
bois francs c'est ça notre justicier
oui c'est ça c'était une chance que
j'avais vous dire c'est le redresseur de
torts c'est à domme d'abord qui qui est
parti d'une basse extraction qui s'est
fait lui même et ensuite qui a décidé de
changer la veuve et l'orphelin de
défendre les pauvres en poursuivant les
mauvais riche et ce rôle de justicier
existe dans toute la littérature
populaire françaises décriées ramener au
personnage une grandeur sera
trop fort mais a amené le côté homme du
monde que qu'on a envie d'être
vous savez l'homme en habit le mans
autre forme il a par sa silhouette et sa
façon d'être un côté aristocratique de
lupin keane je ne pense n'existait pas
dans les premiers le lupin qui ont été
portés à l'écran était plutôt les lupins
un petit parisien puisque c'était robert
lamoureux
c'était très différent et là je crois
que enfin ça a déjà été on l'a vu dans
la première série
il a amené au lupin le lupin qui était
décrit dans le blanc qui est intégrée
dans les dessins populaire de leblanc
c'est à dire une la silhouette
aristocratique le gentleman cambrioleur
un peu mal cambrioleurs sophie agacinski
et le sourire de la garçonne dès
l'épisode allié à arsène lupin contre
airlock ssions mon personnage nathalie
cas des personnages qui vit avec arsène
lupin c'est pas une aventure comme ça
alors qu'elle passe tout l'épisode avec
lui c'est du solide elle l'aide
oui enfin pour un épisode elle l'aide
dans le vol puisque c'était le cas le
collier et c'est une complice quand même
c'est une histoire de collier l'encan au
collier de diamants de requises et ça se
termine comme on pourrait bien le garde
le collier c'est pas très moral ça sert
mais bien l gardarsson aussi non arsène
ne garde pas de femmes tel quel le
retrouvera je sais pas c'était non parce
que nathalie c'est pour ça que j'aime
beaucoup de personnages est une fille de
notre époque c'est une fille qui
travaille est une fille libre une fausse
et une fille émancipée
s'ils voulaient ils se rapprochent de
cyrano de bergerac sommes d'ailleurs
très près de bergerac et de ce
personnage gascon qui a beaucoup marqué
la littérature française il gagne par
l'intelligence ses adversaires c'est un
héros à panache c'est un héros à panache
c'est très vrai
[Musique]